dans la matinée le thermomètre affichait
déjà 20 degrés après la morosité de
l'hiver ce temps estival a ravi les
yvelinois vraiment dans les parcs petits
et grands profitent de ces vacances
ensoleillées
ce que j'aime bien faire quand il ya du
soleil c'est plutôt sortir et jouer au
ballon faire de la balançoire dans mon
jardin est aussi regarder les animaux
qui se promène dans la nature le
programme des prochains jours c'est
peut-être une escapade au bord de la mer
voilà et se balader voilà à penser arias
se vider l'esprit profiter juste du
soleil la chaleur on a quand même eu un
hiver un peu
dure un peu long mais là ça nous a fait
du bien on vient ici le parc est
agréable il ya de l'espace pour le grand
les petits y sont ils sont heureux les
rayons du soleil font du bien au moral
mais aussi aux fleurs dans son jardin en
kz2 faut cultiver une centaine de
plantes différentes
hélas les bananiers bonnes connaissances
sont pas très beau parce qu'on les a
couverts pendant quatre mois d'hiver et
là ça commence mais si un mois venait
voir la différence
ça va monter jusqu'à 2 m chaque année la
passionnée de jardinage ouvre son jardin
aux curieux le retour du soleil est une
aubaine on est bien au rugby on est
content mais on reste la journée dans le
jardin on regarde les pousse à regarder
les semis qui sortent
on est content qu'on voit que ce harvey
tour rubis la verdure reprennent
reprenne le chemin
selon météo france le soleil devrait
encore brillé toute la semaine il y a
comme un air d'été qui souffle sur les
yvelines pour le plus grand bonheur de
ses habitants